well first off how did you two
meet
anything
i um
i i was approaching 40 years old
and thinking that that my lifestyle of
uh
of being
basically
promiscuous wasn't the
the road to happiness and i i just felt
like it's becoming kind of a bad look
and it's i don't want to be that i feel
like if i want to be happy in life i
need to learn how to have a healthy
relationship and so i addressed those
issues
and i got very very serious about sexual
sobriety and at one point uh facing a
bunch of tour dates i just
i needed help
on the [ __ ] blocking side so scott i
said scott
like you know i really want to be
serious about about uh you know a
healthy approach
to my life and and and not acting out
sexually can you come on tour with me
share a hotel room with me
and sell my merch so that you're right
there and actually be a formal
professional cockblocker
and that's amazing um
yes i think of scott
to be the one i'll let
i ran into steve
uh in the same
general area of that uh program we were
both double winners in uh 12-step
recovery meaning that we both had issues
with drugs and alcohol as well as
compulsive sexual acting out and so i
knew that scott was uh
what you know
dealing with the same issues and kind of
on the same page
so as a function of fellowship
and and working towards becoming the man
that the love of my life deserves you
know i had a lot of work to do to get
ready to meet looks you know
and yeah and so that was what brought
scott and i together was uh it was doing
that work
and um scott was scott would take a
bullet for this dick
[Laughter]
yeah i mean
yeah like we we were successful in that
and um and then i started so then the
first oh yeah the first show scott shows
up he's like all you sell is t-shirts
and books you don't even have a credit
card swiper and he put together this
merchandising empire and now all these
years later scott's my tour manager my
business partner my co-producer like my
co-host you know like we've really
really built a lot and and by
by eliminating the distractions and the
stress of all the you know like
acting out it's it's really allowed me
to to narrow my focus and be super
deliberate and not waste my time and and
as a result we've been able to
to achieve some pretty some pretty big
things yeah you got a good circle around
you i feel like that's one of the
the most important things towards
success is just having people around you
that are like going to motivate you in
the right direction and are like-minded
so you guys were like-minded in the
cock-blocking strategy and then
right all the success so far also uh
also you gotta put people around you who
fill in your holes you know like where
like you know scott and i are very much
a yang yin and yang because like
he's he's a morning person like i'm not
you know like i'm like super creative
he's super administrative you know like
we really compliment each other a lot
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude